we live in Africa we didn't have roads
and there's no electricity the odds of
me overcoming all obstacles never mind
the way to the mental health it's like
zero it it's not possible finally what
was gonna happen I know what's gonna get
here they didn't there's a lot of
stressful years a lot of times want to
be happy
build a life not just a business what's
up believe nation its Evan I believe in
you and this channel is designed to be a
part of your daily success routine so
today let's live your best believe life
and learn from three amazing nothing to
greatness stories also if you want to
know what Conor McGregor and others have
to say about building unstoppable
confidence check out my 250 for
confidence series where every day for
the next two hundred and fifty four days
I will send you a morning video for free
to help you build your confidence the
link to join is in a description for the
low I believe you that's what I want to
say because I believe yes I believed in
[Music]
let's kick it off with Story number one
be resourceful with Julius llego I come
from a humble family my parents are just
farmers until now they are still famous
we really laugh cuz we didn't have roads
and there's no electricity in Africa we
always believe going to school is the
best way of getting a better life
my dad was not pleased when I started
dabbling area in school because he
really wanted me to pass through
education but then Norway in Canada you
can have a place for EE in training I
didn't have any quote I was doing
training alone I saw it as like life was
going against me
twas the lowest form
[Music]
but I didn't even give up something came
into my mind
- what the YouTube videos I could go to
the cyber look at a grape javelin
throwers see what they do in their
normal training and I will come and
practice the following day
well you don't have the facilities you
try on yourself to improvise what you
have
the past few years when I was doing the
training alone was a big challenge for
me but now I have partners we train
together
Metro training ez invoice it's fun I
like familiar
the videos of these guys really helped
me a lot in 2010 I throw 75 after that I
keep watching this video
[Music]
in 2011 I want the OL African games it
was the first time that Kenya was
winning a gold medal in javelin
in 2012 when I threw a 2809 scream
because I couldn't believe that I was
making the Olympic final but the first
time somebody in the finals from Kenya
and after class well I didn't stop from
there in 2014 it was a big thing by one
goal for the first time in football
games 2015 is especially upon the world
championships 92 meters you know a big
draw and winning a gold medal I will
never forget that forever
now I'm the world champion it's like a
dream
story number two find your motivation
with Tyson Fury the turning point for me
was I thought it was Halloween last year
um I'd never suffered any more anxiety
attacks or anything since about mid to
late summer uh yeah Oh Ally of seventeen
but I was still drinking and still going
out partying and whatever and in value
nothing at all but every time I got
drunk I'd come over and say right I'm
dying training in the morning regain
mission I'm gonna be the every weight
champion of the world again if you watch
you were 400 pounds 400 pounds that was
a man who called wolf a thousand times
follow me friends up phone chain of gam
all going come on we're gonna do it
Monday Monday come no I do not want a
box anymore finished turning point once
I want out Halloween dressed as her a
skeleton in a fancy dress party about
nine of all can expected to stay all
nine gets smashed I had one drink I
looked around me and I thought what am i
doing I said to myself you're telling me
that you'd rather be here with a lot of
kids half your age because I feel like
the old person now when I go I'm 34 all
18 and like I know it's 21 over here but
overall miss sure 18 they're all 18 19
20 21 and I'm I'm like the old guy in
the disco bopping around I thought is
this it you traded having all I'm
achievements for what
and I knew I couldn't do on my own I
just knew it I couldn't do it I said so
many times I was gonna do and believed I
was gonna do and the night the next day
calm I didn't have no motivation to do
it that's another thing that mental
health will give you know zero
motivation to do anything zero
motivation to have a shave zero to brush
your teeth even have a shower luffing I
got back that night
I mean why fall I was drunk I come home
early shows all your arm early I said
yeah I said I've I don't know for this
life I said tomorrow I said I start to
turn my life around
and this was Halloween night yeah 2017
she said yeah yeah I've heard it all
before cuz I'm the man who cried wolf a
thousand times I said I promise you I
said I'm gonna do it I'm definitely
gonna do it and nobody believed me but I
knew I had a smile on my face twinkling
me I uh I knew I had to get that weight
off by the way at this time I was
working at a 12 year ban I'd failed two
drugs tests for cocaine because all the
time I was out or still doing random
drug tests so I had cocaine in me system
on two x occasions the British box and
border control had suspended me license
I was D medically unfit to fight by the
leading psychiatrist in the country and
I had millions of pounds millions of
dollars in in lawyers fees to pay an
ongoing battle in court cases well I am
so confident that I'm gonna come back
and everything's gonna be swept away the
odds of me overcoming all obstacles
never mind the way to the mental health
it's like zero
E it's not possible he ain't coming back
because he can't from that day I got me
tracksuit on in the morning and I was
gonna run T mile like about 200 yards
and stopped on the far right account I
can't run I've run all my life I've
always been a very good runner
and I got 200 yards and I was totally
gone I could take me belly move and I'm
not it wasn't like a fat like jelly it
was like solid brick it was it was a
horrible feeling of okay I'm gonna walk
the rest and I walked while I was
walking I was on my phone and I saw a
little video from Deontay Wilder and he
said ha
Tyson Theory lay self down lays family
down
he said he's that fat he'd never come
back he said I'm glad he's gone because
I've knocked him out anyway just
rumbling on nonsence here on avoidance
of you know what I'm gonna give it you
proper is you're my motivation now I'm
coming back to get you and and every day
I'd go out on the canal and I do a
little running me sweat suit and every
day get a little bit further until I was
doing fall in a 5-mile again
consistently over every sing ever said
nice never said no there's an over today
now even in the rain that was out when
me Mac on running I'm gonna tell you
something else I've already warned
because we're from I agree win the fight
or not on December the first I'm a
winner
I think it's one of the greatest
contrast I've been back from every
possible disadvantage to be an elf am
studying out 255 pounds in shape in a
mentally great place and I I feel so
great of coffee marks on me but I love
it
I'm in the rings bar and I'm struggling
in the ring because it's so much not
hair but I'm so happy that I'm in there
I'm like I'm back to my love to do and
Story number three the last one before a
very special bonus story is make it
happen with Conor McGregor
[Music]
when I was a kid he's always visualized
Stadium something and like even when I
was playing football I'd kick the ball
against a wall and I would pretend that
I scored a goal and I'd run off and I'd
be raising my hand and visualizing a
arena full of fans Oh Sam I don't as a
kid I'm out on my own I like just
running around kicking the ball I always
had these visions of something but I
just didn't know what it was and then I
suppose when I came to this these events
I know it stopped raining and then came
to an event it was like okay this is it
this is this is what I'm gonna do and
then now I'm dealing but did you ever
have let's call it a normal job Connor a
nine-to-five yeah cuz the artist thing
is the games were trade straight away
him I was no different
soon as I finished school I was always
getting passed with what are you doing
with your life and then they still not
and they didn't know what it was they
didn't know if MMA wasn't know what none
of this didn't know it could make a
career out of as far as day or consent
me mind I'm talking about as far as they
were concerned of just getting into a
cage appointment some other guy they
didn't know nothing about it
no one did really but I knew and I mean
I knew well that and then I got it I end
up getting a trade just to keep them
quiet
zhuzi I had a lot of fights with me dial
up on your trade did you get I end up
getting a trade as a plumber how bad was
a diploma yeah horrendous were you
actually in the trenches I mean it was
in industrial so I'd be like building
this it'd be like diploma that would be
needed
places like this six o'clock in the
morning and the motorway and I used to
have to walk through an hour to get them
to get there on motorway and then I
stand on the edge of the motorway and
wait for a bloke to drive boy so give me
a lift and then the motorway was like an
renovation that time so take me to arrow
to now if I was to get to the place was
out in the country then I'd be there for
10 hours walking and I was a first year
so as the worst of the war sermons on
the beginning then two hours to get back
in the traffic again was just a horrible
horrible time and I was like you know I
don't want to deal with this and then I
just left I lasted 18 18 months stealing
well it was tough you know just it
wasn't I wasn't the life for me and I
mean then and then John said because I
was training with John as well at the
time and then John got on Twitter says
they have a show on the show would like
the fight honey and then that was he I
just packed it in didn't show up we'd I
used to come in and punch the head on me
and like try and drag me out bed and I
just wouldn't go and I hadn't open off
for a good few years with him all verbal
and and that was it I just packed in and
quit and then focused on training that's
I knew I knew I knew what was gonna
happen I knew I was gonna get here they
didn't there's a lot of stressful years
a lot of tough times but I proved them
wrong I proved myself right but
everything I do in my life is is related
to this I don't do nothing else it's
enough
fine by me and that that is why and I
meant it to be true so dearly all you've
got to do is show up
is that not unhealthy I don't know
do I look unhealthy take a look at this
physique I'm in phenomenal shape in body
and mind to me what's unhealthy is
living an unhealthy life to me what's
unhealthy is getting up and go into the
same day every day alike 9:00 to 5:00 in
an office or in it remember that that's
unhealthy
that beats your mind I don't I don't
work I wonder why I love what I do and
that's why I'm doing what I love and I
mean that's why that's why it's become a
career for me because I love it I love
what I do
now I've got a special bonus story with
David Goggins and how to calais your
mind that I think you're really gonna
enjoy but before that it's time for the
three point landing questions time to
move from just watching another video to
taking action in your life or business
and if you're feeling bold leave your
answers in the comments below here we go
question number one what is your
motivation number two how can you be
more resourceful and number three what
will you do today to make it happen
I came home one night from work spraying
for cockroaches and long story short I
turned on the Discovery Channel and I
saw some guys going through Navy SEAL
training and they're going through hell
week and they're getting their ass just
beat you know in out of the water
guys ringing the bell there was
suffering and I was waiting like 297
pounds and I had to make a change in my
life you know I was at all-time low and
I wasn't going anywhere
and I was exactly what everybody said I
was gonna be which was nothing so I had
to make a change what was it about
seeing suffering that's that's really
interesting and I actually get it but I
want to hear you explain it why
suffering was the thing that triggered
that thought well for me growing up I
came from a horrible background I got
called [ __ ] every day of my life
growing up lived in a small town the
Klan headquarters at that time was about
20 minutes from where I lived the one of
the high ups in the KKK son stabbed
behind me in two classes so you called
me [ __ ] a long time I got my first car
they spray print [ __ ] we're going to
kill you on it so I was just an insecure
scared kid and the only way I could find
myself was to put myself through the
worst thing possible I started shaving
my head when I was 16 years old and the
feeling I had every morning I looked in
the mirror was horrible
and I don't want to feel like that
anymore and how I felt was a kid going
nowhere a kid that was scared and most
kids will accept that and look for help
but the best thing that happened to me
no one helped me no one felt sorry for
me no one looked at me and said like
this day and age they'll they'll take
you in and they'll tell you bye stop
picking on this person back then they
didn't care
the KKK marched in our 4th of July
parades they had to stay a hundred yards
back but they marched in it
Wow that's how this town was and my mom
cared about me but my dad took our soul
and she you know did the best she could
I had to figure out I wasn't going to be
a punk kid all my life so anyway I could
turn
was to suffer I had to build calluses in
my brain the same way I built calluses
on my hands so I brought the Ginsberg a
Royals record for pulse a long time ago
but I felt at it twice and I did 67,000
pull-ups in trying to break this record
so to do 4030 pull-ups I had to do
67,000 for training for that Wow and so
what I realized is for me to become the
man I wanted to become I saw myself as
the weakest person God ever created but
I never blamed God for anything he did
to me so I wanted to change that to be
the hardest man ever created in my that
I don't know but you had to have a goal
and my goal when I was sitting there not
going to school being bullied being
having no self-esteem my goal was the
only person that's gonna turn this
person around it's me you know what I
can't turn around is put myself through
the worst things possible a human being
can ever endure it and I'd be the only
way that I can build this brain to
handle anything that comes in front of
it
callus in my mind through pain and
suffering in the end like what would
your advice be to that 16 year old kid
if staring in the mirror does not like
what he sees but is still running from
adversity well my biggest advice to him
is that first of all he won't like what
I say to him okay I'm gonna say the
exact opposite of what the world today's
world is saying so we read a bunch of
books nowadays as humans we we want to
find out how to be someone else what we
don't do is we don't go inside so
literally turn yourself inside out read
the book that says like we're writing a
book every day of our lives but we never
read that book so what I would challenge
this young man or young women to do is
you have to look inside of yourself to
see what you really want what are you
passionate about we use these words and
these little phrases of only the strong
survive and also the crap
they're all just words I get so tired of
hearing people just talking like right
now someone may think doctor is just
talking you don't know me so when I
speak I speak from Pasha I speak from
experience I speak from suffering
I want to tell this young man and woman
that the only way I believe this is just
my experience in life the only way
you're ever going to get to the other
side of this journey is you have got to
suffer to grow to grow you must suffer
and some people will get it and some
people won't but they have to see what
their journey is to start their journey
several people live to be a hundred
years old and they have great lives and
they have great kids that kids go to
college long sort of stuff but somewhere
in their life there was a point where
they had the decision to make
they can go left or right on this path
left was the easy route right was a hard
route a lot of people take the easy
route and they had a good life that way
but the better life was going to the
right side and you may have 20 years of
pain and suffering to get past it but a
lot of us died never truly starting our
journey and I would tell this young
person you got to start your journey it
may suck but it will it will come out
the other side we are coasting
if you like this video check out the one
I did on m'aimes life story I think
you'll enjoy the link is right there
next to me continue to believe believe
and I'll see you there
[Music]